i had a friend hit me up and say you
know there's huge unrest in thailand
right now
will you cover it and i said i've been
following it
but i'm not going to cover it you know
why there's an election happening right
now
and and the most important story to me
that i care about
is the u.s election media censorship
manipulation and what's going to happen
to us
after january 20th if uh
you know six years ago i was in thailand
you know i was in turkey i was in these
countries because that was the most
important thing i could see
things in the u.s were kind of just you
know moseying along
but everything started to change i don't
know where we're where we're ending up
but i'll tell you this there's a lot of
people who seem to think that voting for
joe biden
will bring them back to those good old
days the obama year no
you know it's it's never going back to
normal the the world has changed
fundamentally social media has changed
the game
we are not returning to some some bygone
era
of even five years ago this is it yeah
it's it's it's from here wherever we go
what's your prediction after the with
the social media companies after the
election what do you think's going to
happen so the social media company next
six months what's going to happen
trump and the republicans landslide
across the board then
maybe some kind of section 230 reform
i'm not confident
i mean the republicans controlled
everything from 2016 to 2018 they did
nothing they couldn't they couldn't even
get the fund you know funding for the
wall and stuff like that true
why do you think that is that's an
interesting topic why are the
republicans so weak when they get the
power i have a theory well
my theory for 2016 is that it was
corporate crony establishment
politicians i i've never seen a
difference between the republican and
the democrat i don't care
i used to i made a meme back in the day
on facebook of the republicans and
democrats like holding hands behind your
back
because i view them as fundamentally the
same thing they don't care about
principles
i think it's the dinesh d'souza line
about uh
the the republicans fear the terrifying
and humiliating power of the press
like they don't do the right they don't
do the thing that they reluctant to do
because the media will
crap on them and ultimately what they
want is to be praised by the new york
times because it hurts i mean i can tell
you
and they've probably given him dean back
case satisfaction saying this
i don't it's a difference between
seeking their recognition and knowing
that it's hurtful
you know no one wants to be boycotted
targeted you know
tarred and feathered yep so i think
that's my theory why the republicans you
know capitol hill
republicans aren't cool no and people
want to be cool
and so the republicans have seem to be
especially now
desperately trying to be like hey i'm
i'm a hip new york times look at me i'm
cool i'm like those celebrities
but it's changing it's definitely
changing and i had a conversation
believe it or not there's a lot of
hollywood celebrities rock stars
musicians
artists etc who are secretly pro-trump
and many of them hit me up pro
skateboarders even you know
really definitely oh man you'd be
surprised the soviet union they can't
tell their friends or their family
borders this is crazy to me are uh
not leftists they used to be like when i
was growing up it was like
when it was cool uh you know you know
what it was because
skateboarders oppose the moral
authoritarians skateboarders want to be
left alone
so now you have this moral authoritarian
left insulting attacking
skateboarders like making edgy art they
like pushing security guards running
away and skating and just what do they
do they just message you hey don't tell
anybody
like how do they reach out to you i had
someone message me crying
on the phone just text me like sending
me a message being like i'm in tears
right now i'm crying i'm i'm so scared i
you know i can't believe what's
happening in this country and these are
celebrities and things like that so you
know i bring this up just to say
uh i forgot exactly where i was going to
go with this but my you know
my point from there is there's a lot of
people who
believe it or not are are cool
and don't want to be on the left so that
was kind of the point i was saying is
that republicans aren't cool right
but i've gotten hit up by now probably
like three or four different
cool types i'm and i knew the air quotes
like stereotypically
celebrity hip saying things like the
reason
why they think what i do is so important
is because it's kind of
anti-establishment but i'm not some
suit-wearing republican
yeah you know i'm like beanie and even
getting to know you which i've this is
like the second time i've met you
um you're singing you're singing music
it's beautiful music
good animation you got a good voice
you're you're an artistic
creative individual and a lot of these
people in dc are stodgy they write white
papers they have yeah
they can't dance like you're you gotta
there's a skateboard park on this
property that you built and you sing and
you you know
i find myself the same way i was a
thespian you know before i was a
journalist
um but there's something to that there's
a creative
aspect charisma it's charismatic it's
it's
creativity republicans lack charisma
terrible they're terrible storytellers
oh have you ever seen a movie funded by
conservative money
it's actually going to name any names
it's actually just so funny it's
terrible yeah it's bad i mean
so it's so bad it's getting and when the
left
when the left makes them they just make
a movie when they're right
let's make a conservative movie i gotta
i gotta point this out though
i think things are changing and this is
really really important for
not so i don't think it's about the
right it's about
freedom liberty it's about respect
individualism
and and civil rights and right now the
left doesn't have that
they're moral authoritarians it used to
be the right back when i was growing up
and you know the religious right more
authoritarians putting labels on things
and banning things
it's not anymore so i'm going to point
something out can you change it to
to james's camera again yeah i can up in
the corner of the screen
right behind you there's a picture of
joe biden eating a small child i like
that one
i love this this is uh i this is some of
the best art i've ever seen
i ordered a bunch of these prints from
george alexapolis he's gprime85 on
twitter and instagram
and he makes these really amazing like
comic critiques and and it's art and
it's a
gruesome and grotesque image of joe
biden eating a child
and it's incredible art i mean it's it's
i saw this on twitter and i was trying
to find this guy
it's it's like a satirical exaggeration
of
of what you'd imagine a joe biden
nightmare to be yes
it is it's like that yeah it does that
what's that artist ralph stedman it's
sort of like i got a ralph stedman
ralph said but uh fear and loathing
aspect to it
i bring this up because this is
incredible art
that normally wouldn't be a so you don't
see these things associated with the
rights
but now it's it's this change is
happening and that's i think
there's a couple different ways to view
what's happening whatever it is on the
right
you've got laughter comedy you know they
try to cancel all the comedians
claiming that they're bigots or far
right or whatever
so if you can't have a good time what do
you got but now you've got artists
you've got
video games you've you've got people
that
are now associating themselves with
either trump or just the right in terms
of the culture war
and they are creative and charismatic
and interesting and exciting
and the right needs more of that and i
don't know if it's the right or whatever
you want to call it but
the world well well the world's had it
but whatever's happening right now you
have a lot of people just pretending to
be on the left i guess or they are
and the left is becoming so boring and
corporate and stodgy
and just like plastic it's like
anti-punk rock the right has become punk
what's that this the uh
sex pistols guy johnny rotten yeah make
america great again
yeah he's in for trump and he voted for
hillary in 2016. yeah
so i don't i don't know if trump's going
to win again i
i kind of think he you know i kind of
feel like he is and the republicans i
think are going to win but i i i
have no basis for this other than i
don't think anybody knows what's going
to happen right nobody does and i think
hard predictions are dumb but but but
i'll say this
i think there's a fracture happening in
in reality
i mean you even hear it from the left
that there's two different realities
right now
but i'll tell you what man whatever
we're doing this is the real world
what like the work you're doing the work
we're doing here on the show
is reality and whatever whatever
whatever cnn is doing
is this weird fantasy realm of russian
spies
and trump peeing on beds and stuff but
it it really is insane
it's interesting and people believe
people believe it the difference between
the soviet prop and the american prop is
in
in the united states people actually
believe what they read and soviet union
everyone thought it was a joke
privately when they're in their you know
cottages and they're whispering to their
you know some of their kids some of whom
they didn't even trust they'd sell each
other out
they'd say we all know this is you know
bs but in the
but in but in the united states what
i've discovered and learned and
doing this for 12 years is a lot of
people actually believe what they see
on tv they stay believe it they see it
and they go that is the truth hitler's
minister of propaganda joseph
joseph goebbels i think was his name
would say if a lie is told enough
people believe it is truth yep it's like
a phenomenon that's real
well so look you put out a video
of a guy saying google is doing this
yeah and they say it's a smear yeah you
put out a video of a guy going look at
all the ballots in my hand
i'm gonna get paid for this and they're
like no evidence no evidence no
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you